[Music]
[Applause]
today one of our favorites george kittle
the
49ers tight end on the program
and uh what does it seem like it was a
year ago
you were in the super bowl i think it
was about a year ago yeah
what were you doing a year ago on this
day like wednesday of super bowl week do
you remember
i was probably talking to you because we
had to do media every single day
[Music]
is that bothersome or how bothersome in
retrospect
well like you know in a normal game week
you only have to like talk to
you know your local media like once a
week or they're in the locker room two
days a week three days a week
we don't talk to them every single day
but like going on a podium
like four days a week and i mean you
only get asked so many questions during
super bowl week right
yeah what was the strangest question you
got
i got asked to swear in german by the
same guy like four times and he kept
like giving me a piece of paper with
swear words on it in german and i was
like i don't know what you want me to do
with this dude
i'm just trying to be nice and polite
here man can you stop asking me to swear
on tv
yeah but see that's where your
personality comes back to haunt you
because
everybody thinks oh george kittle he'll
have fun he'll say something silly
so i potentially would but not not in
german i don't i don't know how to speak
that language
what do you remember most about the game
against the chiefs
um i mean i remember all of it
was there one thing that just stands out
that you go damn
oh um i mean after they scored to get it
like within three points we had a three
and out the next drive which
can't really do that when their momentum
shifted and that was kind of the
that was kind of the downhill after that
i saw a special where peyton manning
is breaking down patrick mahomes and tom
brady and if you look at the kansas city
chiefs offense
there's so many things going on in that
offense
now you're on the sidelines watching it
but how different is that from any other
team in the nfl with what they do on
offense
i mean i think it's both of what they do
but also who they have i mean you got
weapons all over the field
um and they have a great offense
coordinator that's you know
getting them in the right positions and
then they got a great quarterback you
know leading the way so
it's their weapons and then also their
scheme is got guys moving around
guys are always open and then at the end
of the day they have guys that just make
the tough play and
that's what good football is when did
you realize that you were going to lose
the super bowl
uh when the clock hit zero that was it
i mean when we uh let's see like we
had an interception the very end of the
game so we're down two scores like 30
seconds left
yeah i mean that's not a very fun
feeling this is national signing day
you take us back to what national
signing day was for
george kittle going to iowa uh yeah i
actually i didn't know i was going to
iowa yet i was probably on a
gray shirt there or my only other offers
were weber state
and uh air force and navy and so i
wasn't entirely sure what i was doing
and then uh kirk ferentz called me at
like 11 or
you know 11 a.m or 12 and he was like
hey we have an extra scholarship that
just opened up do you want to come play
it
and i was like damn straight i do
so you couldn't even do three hats in
the gymnasium and say i'm going to
do didn't you you could have put two
hats out there you didn't even have
enough offers for three heads
i i had three maybe a weber state man
that's a damian lillard went there so
yeah that was for basketball not
but you know you look back on that
weren't you destined to go to iowa
yeah i mean my dad played there he
coached there kirk ferentz was my dad's
office line coach
so yeah i mean we had a couple
connections there uh and just kind of
played out the way they i think they had
three guys that uh declared to go to
other places
on signing day and so i got that last
and final scholarship
but when did it click where you go you
know what i'm pretty good
i can i can play in the nfl um
i don't know when i was like three years
old
that's what i you know that's what i
wanted to do and um you know i've always
done well at football like i've always
been able to make plays but
um i really think going into my what was
that going into my junior year
uh i mean mentally it just everything
clicked for me and i realized that you
know it's not high school there's not
like 10 plays that you're running
there's just a lot more
to it than just showing up and playing
football and um
kind of clicked for me there and then i
had a really good spring ball uh
transition to a good uh you know fall
camp and then good season just kind of
carried on from there
you think you're always going to have
that comparison with kelsey
uh since i think you're both uh the same
age i mean is that a good thing
that hey you know you're looking at
kelsey's numbers kelsey looking at your
numbers or we're looking at both numbers
here
i mean i just show up when i play
football and our numbers seem to be
sometimes consistent with each other i
mean he's having a hell of a year
um breaking records and stuff like that
and averaging like 150 a game it feels
like it's pretty awesome
uh but uh i mean yeah like i said i just
show up and play football then people
like to compare us it is what it is
yeah but i think that you you block
block like gronk and you catch like
kelsey
i mean that's i just that's great
i mean i try to play the titan position
the way it's supposed to be played but
even with you're supposed to say thank
you for the compliment that's the
ultimate compliment
come on what's going on george here i
mean i'm throwing out verbal bouquets
here
oh i appreciate it you know i like i
said um
i don't i don't take on the most you
know i don't i love compliments i
appreciate that
um but like i said i just i like to work
hard and
as long as uh my teammates and then the
rest of league respects the way i'm
playing the game
i'm doing all right what's the
background there you spent no time on
the background there
do you mean the piece next to me no you
got it like the shades are down is that
a like something's hanging up over your
your shoulder there you're that's my
first pro bowl jersey
oh a little tilt to tilt the camera that
way let me see what that is
that's it okay anything else in there
yeah that's that's not a verbal
compliment dan
that wasn't right i'm moving houses so
i'll have all my jerseys right now
there's a wall right here full of like
12 jerseys from guys i like in the nfl
so
you know those are all befriended at
some point did anybody say no to you
when you
asked for a jersey i don't think so
not that i'm aware of actually a couple
so that's pretty fun too
well who who did you get that might
surprise me
who did i uh that might surprise you i
traded jerseys with mike evans at the
pro bowl
um that was pretty fun let's see who
else adrian claiborne he's an iowa guy
and then the rest of them are basically
tight ends i just have a wall of tight
ends
i got bobby wagner chris mccaffrey up
top but uh yeah
i mean i have like yeah 10 tight ends i
like to trade with every single titan
that i play because
i love the position i love everybody
that plays it where are you going to
watch the game
whoo i think my house wherever my wife
tells me to
is she watching with you uh yeah i mean
my whole family lives in nashville so
we'll probably watch it together
does she get nervous what's she like
when you're playing
um let's see she's usually very happy
and she i mean she loves football she
loves watching she loves being in the
stands
um i think i get if i get tackled she
yells at me i can
hear that occasionally from the stand
she's yelling at you
oh yeah
i know you're making a pitch with uh
bolt 24 by gatorade
so uh fill us in cool
finally volt24 gatorade got it right
here with me you can see it all around
oh wow product placement it's natural
right
yeah i'm really excited to work with
gatorade because uh it's a product that
i've
um used my entire life since being a
little kid you know i remember drinking
gatorade after like my
my little pee wee football games and so
being a chance to work with them is
it's kind of a dream come true like i
never didn't think that this was a
possibility but
uh the bolt 24 um it's delicious it's
new
it's amazing but really i think my
favorite part of it it's it's healthier
and it's made with watermelon water no
artificial flavors or sweeteners and
so i really like that and it allows me
to be i can drink it whenever i want uh
because it is healthier and
i have to worry about anything and just
allows me to be the best athlete i can
be every single day
and i'll give you another compliment i
don't think gronk could have delivered
it that way
i think you uh did a great job
delivering that better than gronk could
have
i appreciate that you can take that up
with him i don't know if he'll agree
with you but
okay but since you love all tight ends
you got to pick one tight end to win the
super bowl
which tight end do you want to win the
super bowl wish do i want to win
i mean i want the boat to when i want to
both have 150 yards and two touchdowns
very unlikely george it's very unlikely
they both will win
i've seen uh that is unlikely you're
right it is no
that'd be tough but um say this is my
thinking dan and you can tell me if i'm
wrong okay she's
really good they're clicking right now
often stephen hold on look paulie would
you write this down george's give me
some real deep insights
the chiefs are really good and they're
clicking they're really good they're
clicking and but the buccaneers have tom
brady and i just don't know how to ever
go against tom brady in the playoffs and
or super bowl
have you had a conversation with tom no
i never had the opportunity to play him
oh well see i talked to him on instagram
one time
i was out i dropped my phone that he he
dm and i dropped my um
i was like holy cow you had your moment
well there's always yeah well sorry
about that
hey uh thanks for joining us as always
hope the ankle is uh healing well and uh
thanks for joining us
thanks dan appreciate coming on that's
uh george kettle nine niners tight end
and uh it got shut down
in week eight with an injury at uh
sienna